hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
finde ich zum em start habe ich auch ein
rezept für euch und zwar habe ich diese
em muffins gebacken
ich habe aus modelle schokolade trikots
gebastelt also dekoriert und die dann
auf meine schokoladen muffins
draufgesetzt und da ist noch eine creme
drauf die sie dann auch sehr ins gras
richtig süß vor allem ist rezept
wirklich sehr einfach und sehr lecker
und ihr könnt diese trikots zum beispiel
auch ganz gut vorbereiten
und wenn man die reben gut vorbereiten
kann starte ich jetzt auch zuerst mit
den trikots und zeigt euch wie ich die
hergestellt habe für die trikots benutze
jetzt modelle schokolade weil modelle
schokolade hat den vorteil dass erstens
noch richtig gut schmeckt und sie
trocknet auch sehr gut und behält dann
eben richtig schön ihre form
ich werde zwei verschiedenen trikots
machen und zwar die deutschland-trikots
die türkei die schweiz und österreich
die türkei weil wir natürlich türkisch
sind weitere war mal in deutschland und
österreich und die schweiz weil ich da
auch immer ganz viele zuschauer habe und
jetzt habe ich eigentlich als eigentlich
ziemlich langweilig denn drei rote
trikots und ein weißes und habe jetzt
hier 300 gramm rote modell schokolade
die habe ich jetzt schon weiß geknetet
und wollte jetzt drei millimeter dünn
aus das ist frank demokrat und dafür
einen gibt diese holzstäbchen
hab ich es gleichmäßig ausgerollt ich
habe mich übrigens eben schon beschwert
morath geklingelt alle welt fragt sich
jetzt warum hat er keinen schlüssel
er hatte einen schlüssel aber in den hut
nehmen oder ich verliere sie verlieren
ja die zum fußball und jetzt werde ich
zuerst einmal die trikots ausschneiden
jetzt könnt ihr euch zum beispiel aus
pappe eine schablone machen oder nehmen
durch ein paar aus sicher zur hilfe ich
mache es jetzt mit hilfe von ausstieg
und die trikots müssen jetzt natürlich
klein genug seien dass sie schön auf die
muffins drauf passen
ich habe ziehe einen ausstecher einen
rechteckigen und zwar muss ich das jetzt
quadratisch ausstechen
deswegen mache ich das jetzt hier einmal
so man kann abo was anderes ergebnis
irgendwas mit dem putter dieser besuch
genau zum beispiel und einmal so
ich war übrigens mal ein sehr guter
fußballspieler ich weiß mag den
zuschauern oder zehn jetzt nie warte
jetzt lass mich erst richtig machen und
jetzt mache ich hier weiter und zwar
habe ich jetzt hier dieses quadrat und
jetzt nehme ich da oben also ich jetzt
hier auch vorgezeichnet nehme ich da
oben diesen fall style der weg also
diesen ausschnitt mich nannten sich der
brasilianer
es wird das richtige fußball gespiegelt
hatte sich tommy lee mio und falls er
einen buchstaben ausstecher habt oder
das könnte auch mit einem messer zum
beispiel machen
nehmen wir jetzt noch den teil weg für
die ärmel aber gratis ist echt ganz gut
mit dieser kannte man sich doch mal
einfühlsam zweckentfremden 13 aussteller
zu kaufen
es gibt bestimmt auch so ein trikot
ausstecher aber es geht ja wirklich
super schnell und jetzt nehme ich nur
noch hier oben an der schulter ein
bisschen was weg und dann ist das trikot
erst mal vorbereitet
und soweit ich jetzt noch alle weiteren
machen und zwar mache ich jetzt vier
weiße und den rest mache ich rot
die trikots sind jetzt soweit fertig die
müssen jetzt erstmal trocknen und jetzt
insgesamt etwa zwei päckchen gebraucht
also von dem rot hätte ich jetzt nur
zwei rote gebraucht aber hab auch noch
was übrig und vom weißen habe ich jetzt
nur ein päckchen gebraucht das heißt
wenn ihr jetzt zwölf trikots in der
gleichen farbe macht braucht etwa 200
gramm modelle schokolade
die muss jetzt erstmal trocknen lassen
und in der zwischenzeit schon mal die
muffins vorbereiten und zwar nehme ich
dann mein muffins grundrezepte macht
schokoladen muffins gibt aber noch ein
paar schokostückchen und kirchen mit
rein
die machen zielitz gebacken und auch
bereits abgekühlt und ich hatte leider
keine kirschen mehr deswegen sind da
jetzt noch heidelbeeren und
schokostückchen mit drin
und jetzt kann ich die trikots nehmen
und bemalen ich werde zuerst mal mit den
deutschland-trikots anfangen und nimmt
dafür die lebensmittel farbstifte und
nehmen einfach jetzt die echten trikots
als vorlage und wird selber einfach so
ein bisschen vereinfacht aufmalen
die weißen trikots sind ziemlich einfach
wenn man da immer mit den schwarzen oder
gelben stiften darauf malen kann
und jetzt mache ich noch die roten
trikots und das sind jetzt stellenweise
natürlich auch weiße zahlen drauf oder
auch zum beispiel das weiße vorzeichen
jetzt bei den österreichischen trikots
und da habe ich jetzt weiße pulver farbe
etwas angemischt verkündet and wahl
entweder alkohol oder palm ihn zum
beispiel nehmen also kokosfett alkohol
verdunstet etwas schneller und trocknet
schneller bei palm ihn muss man immer
aufpassen dass es später dann eben nicht
weich oder warm wird weil es ansonsten
schmieren kann dann können dann mit
einem feinen pinsel auch hier die
schriftzüge richtig gut mal
die trikots sind jetzt soweit fertig die
kann ich jetzt erstmal da vorne stehen
lassen und jetzt habe ich ja auch hier
die fertigen muffins und wer jetzt noch
einen topping zu bereiten ihr könnt
jetzt natürlich auch ein top in eurer
wahl zubereiten was auch sehr gut dazu
passen würde vor allem geschmacklich wer
zum beispiel einen teller topping habe
ich auch immer ganz gerne gemacht heute
ich mich allerdings für meinen
frischkäse doping entschieden aus einem
grund rezept ich sage ich aber trotzdem
kurz die zutaten für die creme brauche
ich 200 gramm schlagsahne zwei bis drei
esslöffel butter zucker 250 gramm
frischkäse da hab ich jetzt philadelphia
im doppel kam stufe etwas vanille
extrakt und vier bis fünf teelöffel
sabbath und lebensmittel verpasste in
grün und gelb
ich werde zuerst mal die sahne steif
schlagen da kommen jetzt zwei telefonat
mit rein
erst kurz beruhigen dann kommen die zwei
teelöffel mit rein
die sahne habe ich kurz kühl gestellt
und jetzt gebe ich die restlichen
zutaten also frischkäse und puderzucker
in eine große schüssel die königsstadt
frisch geht und zum beispiel auch
mascarpone verwenden
aber der frischkäse pass geschmack ist
wirklich sehr gut dazu den puderzucker
habe ich vorher durch gesiebt die welt
jetzt etwas süßer mag nimmt drei
esslöffel und wer es weniger sie es nach
nimmt zwei esslöffel da kommt jetzt noch
wann die lecks trakt mit rein und dann
auch von der gelben und grünen
lebensmittelfarbe einfach nur ein paar
tropfen und drei teelöffel sein apparat
und das sorgt dafür dass es eben schön
fest wird und auch standhaft bleibt und
es wird jetzt noch kurz verrührt
wenn ihr dann die gewünschte farbe
erreicht habt könnt ihr jetzt noch die
sahne unterheben
aber wir können auch ruhig ein bisschen
mehr farbe dazu geben denn die sarah
macht das ganze ein bisschen heller die
sahne wird dann untergehoben mit einem
schneebesen
erfreulich die creme jetzt auch spritzen
kann muss ich noch mal für etwa 20 bis
30 minuten kühl stellen und ich habe es
hier bereits auch einen spritzbeutel
sondern ein weg spritzbeutel gerichtet
mit einer glashülle tram und damit werde
ich später die muffins bestritten
die gräben sind gut durch gekühlt und
ich werde jetzt die machens gleich damit
bespritzen
allerdings setze ich jetzt vorher noch
in diesem afx in förmchen und zwar kennt
ihr die auch die euch vor zwei jahren
glaube ich schon mal benutzt
ich habe jetzt hier welche für die
schweiz und für deutschland
für österreich und für die türkei gibt
so ära keine deswegen ist die dänische
aber es passiert trotzdem auch seine
bitterböse in den fernsehen kann
übrigens super backen das hätte ich
jetzt auch vorher schon drin backen
können denn die förmchen fetten auch
nicht durch diese in ihren drin
beschichtet jetzt setze ich die da mal
rein
und jetzt spritzt sich die creme darauf
wie eben gras als muss immer den
spritzbeutel so senkrecht halten und
dann immer wieder hoch gehen
jetzt habe ich eh cupcakes bespritzen
jetzt könnt ihr die trikots schön
drauflegen und weil ich geh jetz auch
modelle schokolade gemacht habe kann ich
sie auch jetzt schon drauf legen da
passiert dann nicht wenn ihr die jetzt
aus von dort machen würde dann würden
die auf der oberfläche etwas feucht
werden und dann ist es besser wenn ihr
sie kurz vor dem verzehr drauflegt es
muss nur aufpassen dass ich immer das
richtige trikot auf den richtigen muffin
setzen
cdc fertigen machens aus und es ist echt
schade dass der buchwert irgendwie fehlt
david bestimmt gerne probiert aber ich
stelle sie auf jeden fall in den
kühlschrank zurück und dann kann er
später problem mehr da ist die muffins
eigentlich elfmal fans machen müssen
weil elf spieler und man kann er zum
beispiel zwei mannschaften machen die an
dem tag spiel oder kinder sogar mit den
muffins auf dem spielfeld spielen das
wäre doch eine idee naja jedenfalls
hoffe ich dass ich dieses video gefallen
hat vielleicht habt ihr jetzt auch
vielleicht konnte ich euch jetzt
inspiriert und ihr werdet diese muffins
nachbacken falls ja dann schickt mir
gern ein foto auf facebook oder
instagram mit eurer lieblings mannschaft
und dann wünsche ich euch ganz viel spaß
und nach backen und wir sehen uns dann
das nächste mal bis dann bei mir spieler
vier mannschaften drei versuchen
naja egal ich sagt nichts dazu buchbar